- In early 2022,
action star and Hollywood
legend Bruce Willis
stepped away from acting.
This piece of news was
particularly poignant
because of the reason for
his retirement: aphasia.
A language disorder
that affects a person's
ability to communicate,
often caused by strokes,
brain injuries, tumors,
or in Willis's case, dementia.
Even though the word language comes
from the Latin for tongue,
language is really more
related to the brain
than any other part of the body.
It's where language happens.
Whether you're shaping
words with your mouth,
signing them with your hands,
or writing them on paper,
the bulk of the work is going on up here.
While there is no one part of the brain
that handles everything speech-related,
there are some areas that are
more involved than others.
Scientists have known this long before
the development of MRIs
and other brain scanning
technologies. How?
Through the study and observation
of patients who have
experienced language impairments
due to brain damage.
By determining what has
been lost or impaired,
neuroscientists have been
better able to understand
how our brains process language
and what language really is.
And now my brain-language connection
will communicate that to you.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky,
and this is "Otherwords."
(upbeat music)
To learn more about the relationship
between language and the brain,
I spoke with Dr. Alexander Tan,
a pediatric neuropsychologist
with expertise in the assessment
of neurological and
neurodevelopmental disorders
in children and adolescents.
So you're a neuropsychologist.
What is neuropsychology?
- The definition of
neuropsychology literally is
the study of brain and
behavior and that relationship.
So as a pediatric neuropsychologist,
we do checkups on
different brain functions,
like attention, memory,
visual perception, language.
And then using those results,
we can assess for brain disorders
and make sure that we are
getting children the treatments
and supports that they might need
and track their development
or their recovery over time.
- When it comes to the connection
between language and the brain,
the first answers were discovered
in sort of a curious way.
Prior to technological
advances in neuroimaging,
like functional MRIs,
doctors couldn't see what
was happening in the brain
and observe what areas lit
up with various stimuli.
The only way to look at the
brain was by opening it up.
In the 19th century,
physicians Paul Broca and Carl Wernicke
separately discovered
two regions of the brain
through conducting autopsies
on aphasic patients.
- [Dr. Tan] Dr. Broca and
Dr. Wernicke were able
to locate specific parts of the brain
that have resulting
impacts on their ability to
either express language
or to comprehend language.
And those parts, now
referred to as Broca's area
and Wernicke's area,
are in the left frontal
or left temporal lobe, respectively.
And that was one of
the first signals to us
that the left hemisphere
is dominant for language.
- For more than 95% of right-handed people
and 60% of left-handed people,
the left hemisphere is
dominant for language.
But that's not to say
that the language party is
exclusively on the left side.
- Now that we've had more
advancements in technology,
different kinds of imaging techniques,
we now are seeing that language
actually involves a lot
of different parts of the brain,
including, you know,
implicating all four lobes,
the gray matter and the white matter,
cortical and subcortical structures.
It's very much a complex ability
that involves communication
and coordination
between a lot of different
parts of the brain.
- When you see an image, say, this one,
you think, "Okay, yeah, sure, it's a ball,
or a car, or a unicorn."
But that's just the result.
Let's backtrack to what
happened on the inside.
First, you process the visual input
so that you could recognize the object.
Then you have to convert the
input into a semantic concept.
From there, you search
through your mental Rolodex
of abstract representations
and pick the concept matching word.
Finally, you articulate the phonemes
that make up that word.
And if just one step
doesn't work properly,
you might not be able
to recognize the object,
or know what it's for,
or find the word you need,
or communicate the word to anyone else.
What is aphasia, first of
all, and what causes it?
- So aphasia is essentially
an impairment in language abilities.
And it is typically caused by strokes,
brain injuries that affect
certain parts of the brain,
or some kind of
neurodegenerative condition,
like dementias or Alzheimer's disease.
- [Dr. Brozovsky] The two
most common types of aphasias
are the ones named after
Broca and Wernicke.
Damage to Broca's area
may cause Broca's aphasia,
or expressive aphasia,
which means you can
generally understand others
but have difficulty
getting your words out.
It might be limited to single
words or short phrases.
On the other hand, someone suffering
from Wernicke's aphasia,
or receptive aphasia,
will have trouble understanding
language, even their own,
but is still capable of
fluid, competent speech.
They may talk in long, nonsensical,
yet grammatically correct sentences.
- [Dr. Tan] There's a white matter highway
between Broca's area and
Wernicke's area called
the arcuate fasciculus
that can be communicates
between the two.
And so sometimes when
there's impact to that,
there's something called
conduction aphasia
where our expression is intact,
our comprehension is intact,
but because we can't integrate the two,
then it's hard for us to
repeat language that we hear.
- In other cases, extensive
deterioration of the brain,
such as various types of dementia,
can lead to global aphasia
where all three factors,
fluency, understanding, and
repetition are impaired.
And what kind of treatments are available
for people who are experiencing aphasia?
- Our main treatment for
the aphasia specifically
usually focuses on rehabilitation
in the form of speech
and language therapy.
We always want to have
supportive treatments in place
for some of the side effects.
Individuals with aphasia
or at risk for things like
depression and social isolation,
you know, our brains deteriorate faster
with the absence of social connection,
so it's really important
for individuals with aphasia
and for those supporting them to find,
you know, alternate ways
to communicate with them
and continue to integrate them socially.
And just making sure that
we're patient with them
as they try to find the words.
- We know that the brain changes
over the course of our lives
and it generally comes to maturity
in the mid to late twenties.
During childhood, our neuroplasticity,
or the ability of networks in the brain
to grow and change,
is at its highest levels.
- If, for example, children
have seizures on the left side,
there's this crowding effect
that we sometimes observe
where language kind of reorganizes
onto the right side of the
brain to preserve itself
and sometimes crowds
out the other functions
that were typically associated
with the right side.
So sometimes resulting in weaknesses
to non-verbal and visual skills.
- So is the brain prioritizing language
above significant other
functions in general?
Is that something that the
brain generally prioritizes?
- Yes, the brain does tend
to try to preserve language abilities.
You know, language is so important
to be able to communicate,
to learn, to navigate the world socially.
The brain will reorganize however it can
to make sure language
function is preserved.
- Is it possible to improve
your neuroplasticity
as an adult?
- Yeah, sure, there's always ways that,
you know, the typical things
that our doctors tell us
that we never listen to, right?
Making sure that we're really
taking care of our sleep,
our exercise, our diet.
Learning a new language
is a really great one
that really forces our brain
to activate all those parts of the brain
that are really important for
not just language learning
but also code switching
and executive functioning.
- The brain is an incredibly
capable and resilient machine,
and scientists are learning new things
about the brain-language
connection every day.
What is something you've
learned about the human brain
over the course of your career
that you think everyone should know?
- The number one thing I've
learned about the brain
is just that there's always
more to learn about the brain.
We've made big, you
know, very large strides
in terms of understanding how
parts of the brain correlate
with brain function,
but there are just so many
answers that we still don't have,
and that's just what makes it
eternally fascinating to me.
- Language is one of the
things that makes us human,
and because of that,
it is invaluable to us as a species.
Any loss of language or
communication ability is a tragedy.
But by the groundwork laid
through studying language
through the lens of brain damage,
we've come to understand the pieces
that make up human language,
how injury affects them,
and how to apply that information
to improve the lives of
those who are affected.
You may also remember
from a previous episode
that swearing relies just as much
on the right side of the brain.
So don't expect someone
with left-side brain image
to swear any left.
Left? Oh no! (laughs)
(crew laughs)
(bright music)